en plateau virginie hertz bonjour
virginie d'abord comment expliquer cet
empressement de la justice ukrainienne
on le voit on l'a vu dans le sujet la
procureure générale dit que le message
c'est il n'y aura pas d'impunité toute
personne impliquée dans des meurtres des
crimes de guerre sera jugé c'est
vraiment le pari que fait la justice
ukrainienne et c'est véritablement un
test pour elle parce que cette justice
se craignaient juste avant la guerre
était dans un encours de réforme
profonde parce que justement elle
essayait de mettre en place la fin d'un
système de corruption généralisée donc
c'est un test d'exemplarité le pays doit
montrer qu'il est capable de mener à
bien des procès en bonne et due forme en
respectant les droits aussi de de la
défense et sans faire payer à entre
guillemets des des petits poissons on va
dire les les ordres qui ont été passés
au dessus de cure à tout un travail à
faire aussi sur la chaîne de
commandement alors certains experts
disent attention ces procès risque
d'être bâclé ça va être des exercices de
communication avant tout dans la guerre
de l'information qui est menée avec avec
la russie et c'est sûr qu'il ya cet
aspect cet aspect là aussi d'autant plus
que à moscou on commence à dire qu'il y
aura des procès pour des soldats
ukrainiens notamment sur ceux du
bataillon azoff qui sont évacuées ou
transféré depuis à marioupol aujourd'hui
est que les russes accusent d'être
d'être des nazis et qui vont servir
certainement un moment donné deux
monnaies des changes dans des
négociations
voilà donc pour cette justice donc ça se
passe vraiment en ukraine par la justice
ukrainienne ya d'autres procès plus
internationaux qui se dessine d'ailleurs
le procureur de la cpi la cour pénale
internationale était la semaine dernière
à abuja pour enquêter justement oui
alors la cour pénale internationale
c'est l'une des institutions
internationales qui se rend sur place
qui va enquêter 42 ans créateur c'est le
plus gros dispositif que cette cour est
mis en place depuis le début de son
existence il ya également l'onu la
commission des droits humains de l'onu
qui a lancé des investigations et
également la justice de différents pays
notamment
l'allemagne l'espagne la suède ou encore
la france au nom de la compétence
universelle qui et qui dit que tout pays
enfin on peut se saisir de crimes de
guerre commis dans un autre pays parce
que c'est des crimes qui concerne
l'humanité toute entière ce qui est
nouveau en fait c'est quand même qu'il
ya une coopération entre ces différents
échelons
et notamment par exemple la cour pénale
internationale va travailler avec
l'union européenne dans le cadre d'un
organisme qui s'appelle eurojust je vais
pas rentrer dans les détails mais il va
y avoir de la mise en commun de
documents de preuve et ça c'est vraiment
le noeud de toutes ces enquêtes de tous
de tous ses procès qui vont avoir lieu
au point que certains estiment que 76
ans après le procès de nuremberg qui a
été le début de la justice
internationale on rentre dans une
nouvelle ère une ère avec peut-être plus
de coopération peut être plus de
synergie et peut-être aussi justement la
mise en commun de preuves de preuve à
l'avenir mais voilà tout ça était
demandée depuis longtemps par les ong et
visiblement c'est en train de se mettre
en place peu à peu avec des débouchés
qui paraissent possible une condamnation
de vladimir poutine alors là ça s'est il
va falloir remonter effectivement la
chaîne de commandement pour l'instant
c'est trop tôt pour le dire là on voit
ce premier procès qui est celui d'un
simple soldat entre guillemets qui a
d'ailleurs plaidé coupable et l'a
reconnu les faits il a dit qu'il avait
juste on lui avait donné l'ordre de
tirer il avait il avait tiré il y aura
d'autres procès qui vont suivre toujours
de la part la de la justice ukrainienne
et notamment dans quelques jours un
soldat qui est accusé d'avoir tué un
homme violé sa femme devant leur enfant
de 4 ans est ce que lui aussi va plaider
coupable en disant on m'a donné l'ordre
de faire ça voilà il va falloir m'ont
remonté au fur à mesure et c'est pour ça
que la justice ukrainienne comme la
justice internationale c'est vraiment
précipités sur place pour essayer
d'avoir et d'accumuler le maximum de
preuves c'est un début merci beaucoup
virginie sur le terrain bien sûr le
conflit